in this new phase of the pandemic let's
review what we know it's true we don't
know jack and it's not our fault after
all it's called a novel virus it's novel
and it's a virus which means we can't
even see what we're talking about it's
as invisible to us as truth is to CNN
which makes it scary how scary well the
New York Times just did a piece on
quarantine with a ghost
yeah rather than focus on real stuff
they covered unexplained activities
during house arrest
shaking window shades rattling doorknobs
cold water in the shower and Joe Biden
in the basement of course sometimes
houses creeks and plumbing acts weird
but that's my post burrito stomach not a
story so it's got to be a ghost oh yes
the light flickered must be a ghost I
put my house keys away but now they're
on the floor must be a ghost not the
fact that I've been drinking all day and
everything's on the floor including me
now I'm not saying ghosts don't exist
look what I found in my sock drawer look
I get it
if the most likely explanation for
something ie the truth doesn't grab you
there's no story
a ghost is so much more fun than not a
ghost who cares if it's false
the only thing missing though is gender
or race I anticipate a follow-up piece
with old white sexist ghosts you know I
swear I saw a ghost
and he kept checking out my breasts or
worse the ghost didn't actually call me
a racist name but I could tell he voted
for Trump why can't ghost be racist or
sexist aren't we already according to
the media we don't need a pulse to be
hateful see Donald Trump who once again
blamed China for the virus you've said
many times that the u.s. is doing far
better than any other country when it
comes to testing yes why does that
matter why is this a global competition
to you if everyday Americans are still
losing their lives and we're still
seeing more cases
every day well they're losing their
lives everywhere in the world and maybe
that's a question you should ask China
are you saying that to me specifically
I'm telling you I'm not saying it's
specifically to anybody I'm saying it to
anybody they ask a nasty question like
that you know we're this way what we saw
in that exchange Aliso Jiang is
something that has racial overtones it
is racist to look at an asian-american
white house correspondent and say ask
China so for the Pillsbury Doughboy to
believe his own droppings he has to
pretend the last four years of this
didn't exist China China China China
China China China China look it came out
of China okay
how did bright miss that well with the
exception of meals he misses a lot of
things you want a pattern of behavior
here he is claiming the right obsesses
over Russia so disappointing to look at
what we're seeing from right-wing media
these days where there's such an
obsession with the deep state and these
revelations about the Russia probe so
disappointed again for him to say that
without puking he must ignore this
what does Putin have on Trump has Trump
been compromised this is the letter of
intent for the proposed Trump Tower
Moscow some serious people in and out of
government asking whether a u.s.
president might be some kind of
unwitting or witting Russian asset
whether the President of the United
States is an agent of a foreign power we
all know the president's no collusion no
obstruction mantra we know it's false do
you still believe the president could be
a Russian asset I think it's possible
oh man when CNN says you're obsessed
it's like a drunk saying that your
breath smells of rum their success
relies on no one else having a
short-term memory here's Chris Cuomo
blaming Fox for future deaths everyone
around him has a mask on he doesn't
because he wants to keep up the Fox
force this BS that kovat 19 is overrated
I guess the anti elitist over there are
ok with 10
thousand more dead so how does this bozo
get away with that I think he hopes you
forgot about the thousands of real
deaths in rest homes which happened
under his brothers watch during that
travesty what did Chris ask his bro do
you think'll that you are an attractive
person now because you're single and
ready to mingle do you really think you
are some desirable single person and
that this is not just people's pain
coming out of them
you know I hate rehashing this but when
that jerk tries to lay 10,000 dead
future bodies on us we got to show you
that the dead already exists and it hits
a little closer to his home for Chris
than he'd like to admit so how do you
respond when someone accuses you of
wanting death just because you want to
feed your family by getting back to work
just say this if you want us to stay
inside you must really love spousal
abuse because domestic violence
according to The Times is surging under
the shutdown is it true that you'd like
to see more abuse spouses Chris it
sounds absurd because it is but that's
how the media smears you plus they
always have the answers but only after
the fact which makes me wonder where the
hell were you guys back when this
pandemic started why did you hold out on
us it's criminal that you had the answer
key kept it hidden until after all this
death fact is anyone who says they know
is full of it not just the media but
experts too they got so many things
wrong masks shutting down travel
ventilators sending contagious people to
rest homes but if no one knows anything
you might as well invite anyone to
discuss a pandemic CNN at Greta
Thunderbird on a virus special maybe
because they put more value on her cool
words than the actual virus briefings
they skipped Greta call cited the
importance of science a straw man
argument since who's not pro science and
then she linked it to her crusade
climate apparently she pledged 100 grand
to UNICEF which is awesome
damn when I was 17 all I had was a BB
gun and a stack of Swank's that I stored
in a tree if this is a trend for CNN I
can't wait to see who they choose for
future specials the 20/20 election with
Greta thunbergii
race in America with Greta thunbergii
are ghosts real with Greta thunderbird
but you know they could do worse
have you seen their nightly lineup it's
a strange thing how they keep trying to
make this pandemic political you can't
blame Trump for that first he shut down
the economy then he doled out trillions
now he's desperate to reopen what
political side is that he's all over the
place just like America here's how you
know this new red vs. blue division is
bogus the media can't figure out how to
cover the states they want to find
failure in red states and gloats and
successes and blue states and Cheer but
so far that's not happening also the
right tends to be risk-averse the left
it's the opposite yet those who want to
go back to work are portrayed as right
ring and skull and those scolding us to
stand indefinitely aren't so the script
is flipped meaning it's not right versus
left
instead it's media versus Trump whatever
he's for they have to be against at
least you're different smarter you get
it in a world in which we face something
we've never faced we're lucky we have 50
experiments going on at once and each
experiment can run a dozen more each
state can try out a plan some might do
great some might not but we can compare
and contrast its genius without trying
it's exactly what you would do if you
don't have the right answer yet
idiots would prefer one date for the
whole country to go back which is like
placing all your chips on one number on
roulette it feels great if you win but
you likely lose your shirt and here
shirts equal lives as opposed to the 50
state route it's like your 401 K it's
not all one stock it's a portfolio to
hedge against risk it's smart and
unavoidable and we're going to learn a
lot we're gonna finally see the truth
that have eluded us these past months no
more ghosts it'll just be brave
Americans getting up and going to work
and protecting each other the best they
can with simple consideration and the
kind of common sense that elected Trump
over Hillary it's the great American
challenge of your lifetime I think we're
ready let's welcome tonight's guests you
can't lose when he talks news Washington
Times opinion editor Fox News
contributor Charlie hurt he's got more
singles than a strip club
ATM singer songwriter hosted the pursuit
on Fox Nation John Rich
she says fiery as she is wiry host of
sincerely cat on fox nation cat Tim and
every boat he's on becomes a submarine
my massive sidekick and hosts of nuff
said on Fox Nation Cyrus all right
Charles welcome back what do you think
of the shame and blame game you see
among the media oh it's incredible and I
think you're exactly right that
monologue should have been in the
Federalist Papers it is a perfect
enunciation of federalism it's exactly
what the founders intended and it is
exactly how you get through something
like a pandemic you have 50 experiments
you have 50 different efforts everybody
and we can all assume we can just assume
that everybody every governor in America
wants to do whatever they have to do to
save lives Rand they're gonna be
different ideas for doing that and we
can pick the good ones and learn from
the bad ones but of course the dichotomy
here is between people who hate Trump
and Trump and it's no matter what Trump
does they hate him and and and you get
this real sense that they're actually
rooting for failure because they want to
see Trump fail exactly you know John if
you want to reopen your restaurant or
bought a bar people are gonna say you
want people to die that's how they
reason you actually had a tweet that
said that to me today because we
reopened redneck Riviera here in
Nashville of course right along with
state guidelines city guidelines and
somebody actually said John Rich's new
records
be called I killed my fans for money I
mean like just insanity but you know you
can't listen that nonsense because
that's obviously you know we're trying
to get our country back open safely just
like Charlie just said and that's
exactly what we're doing
yeah and cat you know no one knows when
to open and no one knows like it will be
too early or too late but there's no
exact date the only way to do is to find
out with these 50 openings and see the
interaction between the states and the
virus that's what we have to do right no
I disagree I think that what we should
do is just remain closed indefinitely
and focus on calling Trump racist over
anything and everything that's really
important right now especially in
situations like this right where I'm so
glad that you brought that up in your
monologue because China has been
covering up the severity of its
coronavirus okay crisis for a while now
right and why do people cover things up
to make themselves look better what is
it to make yourself look better it's to
engage in competition okay that's
clearly what he meant you don't need a
PhD in social justice to figure that out
you need a dictionary and the ability to
read like he was making a point worth
making so what should he have done he
should have just said you know what
you're Chinese so I can't answer that
you asked me that but if a white
reporter asks me then I can totally
answer it I need yeah like what does he
want people to do to do yeah I can't
answer that
so Tyrus this is like a brave new world
and yet we have a media that keeps lazy
basically crapping on our citizens for
their individual concerns they're not
cutting them any slack which drives me
crazy I know it's not a question well
yeah it was a statement but I got you
the the thing about it is we can we have
to make decisions we have to make
personal individual decisions in this
country I'm pretty soon and I think
that's the whole point of what it is to
be an American we have the guidelines
from the CDC we have things we can do
but we know now that there's sharks in
the water we know that whether we stay
indoors
we go outdoors we'll run the risk we can
take precautions we can make that
decision but we need to be allowed to
make that decision if if a man wants to
open up his restaurant under those
guidelines and I decide to go to his
restaurant because I'm following my
guidelines and I want to take that
chance yeah that should be there should
be no argument for that that should be
fine we know what's going on it's just
whenever they try to make medicine
science political it never works and
this is where people are making their
own decisions and that's what it's all
about